as you know we're currently crowdfunding
Snow White and the Widow Queen a
beautiful storybook uh written by myself
and illustrated by Heather pollington
and I thought it'd be a great time to
feature some old Patron only videos that
interpret fairy stories and so the last
one we put out was Jack and the
Beanstalk which talks about hierarchy
and moving up and the seed and I in
contrast with that I had also done an
interpretation of The Princess and the P
which is related to Jack and the
Beanstalk might sound strange but uh go
ahead and enjoy and you'll see how it is
that those two stories are related
[Music]
this is Jonathan Pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
[Applause]
so we're going to talk about the
Princess and the Pea The Princess and
the Pea is a fairy tale which was
written by KRON Hans Christian Anderson
and usually I don't like to interpret
fairy tales that are and have an author
you could say that are written by an
individual but uh because this story has
an interesting relationship to Jack and
the Beanstalk which I interpreted last
time I thought it would be uh it would
be a good way to show people how these
themes connect to each other and how
they have surprising links between
stories story of The Princess and the
Pea is very simple most people know it
very well a prince is looking for a
princess but
every princess that he meets he uh
he doubts whether or not she's a real
princess and so he goes out on a trip
and he travels all the different
kingdoms around his own kingdom to find
a real princess but every time he meets
a princess there's something off about
her you know she's too tall she's too
pretty she's not pretty enough she's uh
she has certain faults which means that
she is not able to see her he always has
doubts on whether or not she's a real
princess
and so he comes back to the kingdom
disappointed that he wasn't able to find
his real princess and one day a strange
woman comes to the door knocks on the
door of the castle they let her in she's
she's drenched he's dripping wet and all
she can say is I'm a real princess
and so the prince is astounded to hear
her say something like that but they
don't know whether who she is they don't
know where she's from they have no idea
whether or not what she's saying is true
and so the mother of the prince uh
devises a test to find out whether or
not this is true she places a p at the
bottom of 20 mattresses and 20 uh
blankets and the princess you know dries
herself gets dressed for the night and
then she sleeps on these 20 mattresses
now the next day when they wake up the
the mother asks the princess whether or
not she slept well and the answer is of
course no I didn't sleep well there was
something keeping me up there was
something hard in the bed which was
preventing me from sleep and through
that that is how they recognize that in
fact the princess is a real princess and
the prince and the princess get married
and they live happily ever after now
the story might seem very strange at
first glance uh but oh there's always a
a question we need to ask why these
stories persist why they continue to to
uh gain our attention
um and a way to look at the manner in
which there's meaning in this story is
to see it related to the story of Jack
and the Beanstalk I talked about the
story of Jack and the Beanstalk in my
last uh interpretation of a fairy tale
in that story the mother is a widow and
she's very poor and one of the
characteristics that she has is that she
is when uh Jack presents her with the
magic beans she is incapable of
recognizing the value of the beans you
could say that she's incapable of
recognizing the seed
and there's a relationship with her
being a widow not having having lost
seed having lost the the the the man in
her life having lost the father of of
Jack
um being adrift you know and also not
having access to meaning there's a
relationship between that
um
and her incapacity to recognize the seed
to recognize the the being that Jack
presents with her now in the story of
the princess you can see that it's the
opposite the way to recognize whether or
not the woman is the princess is her
capacity to recognize the seed is her
capacity to be sensitive and to discern
the seed even though it is very far away
from her and under all these different
mattresses in the structure you can also
see a very interesting idea which is
that the mother is a poor Widow so she's
down below and she can't recognize the
scene uh so the so Jack has to climb up
above and get it from the hierarchy in
this story it's the opposite the
princess is up above on the 20
mattresses and the 20 quilts and she has
to be able to recognize the seed which
is below she has to be able to find in
the uh the the potentiality that is
below below the Earth you could say she
has to be able to discern the the seed
so
the symbolism is very much related to
the masculine feminine symbolism in in
fact you could say that with the
princess has to show is that she is what
we could call The Good Earth in the
parable of the sower you see there the
the story of Christ in the parable of
the sower Christ throws the seed out uh
on the ground some seed Falls next to
the path and so it can't find its roots
uh and and so the birds come and take it
away another one Falls in these rocks
and so it's not the right type of Earth
and so the seeds aren't able to have
good roots and so when they come up they
die
um and so
and and some of the seed you know Falls
in The Good Earth and the sea that falls
in The Good Earth is able to produce a
tree and is able to produce the uh the
fruit of the of the seed and so you
could say that
the The Good Earth is the earth which is
capable of
recognizing uh you know being a host to
the seed and we can see that there's a
relationship in in all of that because
the prince goes out into the world he
goes very very far away he goes on this
journey to find the princess and and
there's a relationship between that
going out very far trying to find good
potential you could say out in the world
and the stranger who presents herself to
the door and so the stranger has the
relation has this idea of being this
potentiality this unknown potentiality
which presents itself to you uh you know
this this this kind of dark possibility
you know she's she's wet she's covered
in water and so there's this
relationship also between chaos she
arrives during the storm so there's this
this strange unknown potentiality which
presents itself to to the prince
um and the prince has to discern whether
or not this potentiality is the uh the
the right potentiality for him so
imagine this is this is just something
which is
related to everyday life so you know you
have some possibility which presents
itself to you some opportunity a job
opportunity someone uh you know comes
through your door and and talks to you
about something that they want you to
get involved in and the question is you
know you have to now discern whether or
not
this is a good potential a good
potential for you whether or not this is
the right job whether or not this is
something you should get involved in
because there are all these ma all these
things always present themselves to you
and you have to find a way to know
whether or not these this is the right
possibility
and the way that you know whether or not
it's the right possibility is the
capacity of that possibility to
recognize your seed to know to be able
to connect with you in a in a in an
almost sexual manner in order to to give
forth some fruit in the in the future
for it to to produce fruit something
like that
um and so the princess herself with
what's interesting to know is
you can notice that in the story there's
a this idea of memory I've told you
about memory in other talks this idea
that memory is what connects you to the
center to your meaning even though you
move far away so you have some core some
identity something which uh which uh is
the most important thing about you
something which uh makes you something
and as you move further and further away
you know you're always in a danger of
forgetting of not being able to stay
connected to that Center and in the
story what you're seeing is the capacity
of the princess to discern the seed
from far away and so you you have these
layers and layers and layers imagine
them as as these multiple garments of
skin that I always talk about these
multiple garments that are added and
added and added and the the question is
are you able to still stay connected to
the center even though you're far away
and the story presented in a very very
intelligent and subtle way because it is
it relates it to sleep
now sleep has to do with death has to do
also with distraction I told you before
the story of the disciples Christ uh
comes to mount Gethsemane and he goes up
the mountain and he tells the disciple
as Christ is leaving them you know
moving further away from them he tells
them you know stay awake do not fall
asleep stay awake and pray but as he
leaves them they get they've they get
distracted and they fall asleep and so
this is the story of the princess on the
top of the mattresses the idea is that
she's incapable of being distracted
she's incapable of falling asleep
because she is so sensitive that she is
able to discern the center discern the P
from very far away and so she she
doesn't forget she's incapable of
forgetting and it's funny because in the
story it's almost it almost seems like
it's a um
like she's like she's too she's too
difficult you know she's so difficult
that she's capable of sleeping on these
20 mattresses but that's what makes her
the princess because even though she's
very she could be very very far away
she's this strange possibility which
presents itself to them you know this
this chaotic potential it she is capable
of being connected to the seed even
though she comes from far away she's
able to not forget to to not be
distracted by death by Sleep by all that
imagery of of moving out moving away
from from your core from your identity
and so I think this this can also be
related to the notion that even of
fidelity the idea of a the idea that the
princess will remain uh
will will remain true to the prince
because even though she's very very far
away she will not forget the seed not
forget the meaning not forget her her
connection uh to to that reality to her
it to her wedding with the prince and so
all of these things are kind of in
implied let's say in the story uh in the
story symbolism so uh so I hope that
this can help you understand how this
story relates to Jack and the Beanstalk
but also relates to our very existence
and how this notion of The Good Earth or
the good potential is capable of
recognizing meaning capable of being
connected to meaning even though it
comes from far away or even though it is
something which is moving away from the
center
[Music]
thank you
I'm Jonathan Pedro and I'm inviting you
to participate with us in our retelling
and our celebration of one of the most
iconic fairy tales of all Snow White
a beautifully Illustrated storybook Snow
White and the Widow Queen places our
iconic character at the beginning of
eight upcoming fairy tales which will
speak to each other and harmonize in
surprising ways Snow White and the Widow
Queen rekindles an adventure which will
make you remember ReDiscover but also
Marvel and wonder at our Rich Heritage
of stories a Heritage that still has
secrets to reveal even after centuries
of being passed down to us in the past
few decades we have watched many of our
stories our fairy tales our myths become
completely exhausted by efforts to
deconstruct them to reinvent them and
sometimes to even invert their original
meaning
it has come to a point where we've
almost forgotten why we cared about
these stories in the first place
I firmly believe that for this reason it
is now time to retell and redisrupt our
original fairy tales in a spirit of
celebration of admiration and unashamed
joy
I've spent the past two decades
meditating on the strange narrative
elements of Snow White and other fairy
tales after much thinking I'm now
bringing this story to our common Hearth
we find in the fire of time ready to
present Hidden Treasures most of us have
never noticed to accomplish this I have
paired up with Heather paulinton a
world-class artist and designer who has
worked on some of the most beloved film
franchises of our time her work mirrors
my writing and a collaboration that has
produced a powerful synthesis of
medieval style with the best of 19th and
20th Century illustration I love the
kickstarter model because we can make
the book more and more beautiful with
every stretch goal who can offer art
prints a limited edition drawing by
Heather and even a snow white
illustration of my own
finally we're planning a super exclusive
leather-bound Edition which pulls out
all the stops a storybook mantelpiece
for sure
profits of this crowdfunder will be used
to start a new Publishing Company
symbolic World Press whose christening
publication will be this very fairy tale
series
each book illustrated by world-class
artists Jack and the Beanstalk
Cinderella the Valiant little tailor and
several more are next in line for
publication all existing in the same
world and all fitting together like a
puzzle moving towards the final
surprising resolution
after all that there's no limit to what
we can do
it's time to reset the clock to retell
our stories so please join us in this
celebration and create Adventure
[Music]